au Manitoba un rapport de l'unité
d'enquête indépendante qui est à peu
près l'équivalent de leur bureau des
enquêtes indépendantes donc un rapport a
conclu qu'un policier ayant tiré une
balle dans la jambe d'un suspect qui
était armé d'un couteau n'a pas agi
conformément à ce qu'on enseigne au
futur possible
l'insistance s'est produit au mois de
septembre dernier le policier n'a pas
été accusé alors on saisit l'occasion
pour revenir sur cette question qui nous
est posée régulièrement pourquoi les
policiers ne tirent pas dans les jambes
quand il y a un suspect menaçant pour
évidemment discuter de cette question en
juin stéphanoise qui est un ancien
superviseur de SPVM c'est un expert en
usage judicieux de la force il est dans
nos studios de Québec bonjour Stéphane
bonsoir Isabelle alors d'abord
dites-nous dans quelle circonstances un
policier est justifié d'ouvrir le feu
sur quelqu'un
en fait les circonstances c'est toujours
en fonction de la résistance du
contrevenant a donc ce qu'on se base
c'est le modèle national au Québec
madame national d'emploi de la force au
Canada c'est la même chose donc quelle
est la résistance qu'on a à faire face
devant nous et là on a des options de
force qui vont être peut-être à déployer
ce qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
l'utilisation de la force mortelle donc
ça c'est à la base c'est ce qui va ce
qui va motiver notre analyse puis
sûrement aussi l'urgence d'agir est-ce
que est-ce que je dois agir maintenant
est-ce que je peux attendre un peu et il
faut faire aussi la distinction entre le
tir visé et où ce qu'on a le temps de
prendre une action et un tiré actif ou
ce que quelqu'un un suspect armé fonce
sur sur le policier donc c'est une
réaction réaction et il y a vraiment une
différence au niveau de l'analyse dans
ce genre d'intervention là on a pas
beaucoup de temps pour analyser
effectivement Stéphane j'ai toujours
entendu que les policiers devaient viser
le centre masse c'est toujours ce que en
cours dans toutes les enquêtes du
coronaire dans tous les procès qu'est-ce
que c'est expliquons ça encore une fois
qu'est-ce que c'est le centre masse
j'adore l'image que vous projetez en
même temps que je discute parce qu'on
voit la cible lorsqu'on fait les
qualifications on tire vraiment ce qu'on
peut définir comme la centre mère c'est
vraiment la ligne des épaules avec la
ligne du bassin donc la grande partie du
corps ce qui est ce qui est visible
c'est là qu'on va vraiment former les
policiers à faire feu donc c'est la
norme maintenant est-ce que dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles puis là je
parle vraiment d'exception des policiers
qui seraient sur entraînés ou que ça des
tireurs d'élite ou qui ont vraiment des
capacités opérationnelles
supérieur
exceptionnel est-ce que c'est possible
dans certaines circonstances de faire
feu ailleurs oui mais ce n'est pas
enseigné parce que les policiers normaux
n'ont pas assez de formations et de
maintien de compétences pour
pour être sûr et certain d'arrêter de
menaces c'est le but de faire feu sur
une menace c'est qu'il y a un arrêt
média d'une action offensive quand on
quand on craint pour sa vie ou pour
celle de personnes alentours les membres
des décors de police de les policiers je
m'imagine qu'ils sont protégés par la
loi quand ils utilisent la force peu
importe laquelle
tu as fait l'article principal qui
permet aux politiciens de la force et un
article cocotte criminel article 25 donc
si le poly le policier évalue que le
suspect est en mesure de causer des
liaisons corporelles ou la mort par ses
actions le policier va être motivé
légalement d'utiliser le niveau de force
nécessaire bien entendu il faut que ça
soit une force convenable raisonnable et
nécessaire selon les circonstances donc
chaque circonstance est différente ça va
être au policier de motiver pourquoi
dans les circonstances dans
l'environnement selon l'agression envers
le policier ou envers un citoyen
pourquoi le policier du prendre action
et c'est la Saint-Vincent qui protège
également les policiers bon dans le cas
du Manitoba c'est un peu particulier
cette histoire là parce que il le fait
une utilisation non conforme en fait non
d'enseigner le lieu tiré dans les jambes
évidemment c'est la meilleure chose qui
est arrivée parce que il n'a pas été
blessé il n'a pas tué le suspect il l'a
atteint dans une jambe c'est une presque
une chance si on peut dire mais est-ce
qu'il pourrait y avoir des conséquences
légales à ne pas utiliser de façon
conforme la force
je suis pas j'ai pas que les détails
précis de du corps mais certaine c'est
ça c'est que si le policier a pris la
décision de tirer un peu plus bas c'est
à dire aller au niveau du des jambes ou
du bassin est-ce que est-ce qu'il visait
les gens mais ce qu'il faisait le bassin
puis atteint les jambes sont c'est pas
maintenant c'est pas ce qui est enseigné
mais je pense pas qu'il y a des
conséquences au niveau du corps de
police
mais c'est pas recommandé parce que ta
première base on a une philosophie qui
s'appelle la philosophie de la balle
magique c'est pas vrai que le seul balle
va arrêter une menace immédiatement il y
a parfois des agressifs ou qui sont
intoxiqués ou qui ne sont tout
simplement pas là qui vont continuer
avant qu'une réaction biomécanique se
fasse qui vont continuer d'attaquer vers
vers un policier et ça peut être prendre
quelques secondes avec la personne tombe
au sol donc on veut vraiment
et viser dans une cuisse si c'est le but
bien si on atteint la fée morale
l'artère fémorale qui passe dans la
cuisse ben en 50 secondes 60 secondes le
corps se fait de son 500 donc ça veut
pas dire que la personne ne décède pas
non plus de ses blessures donc c'est pas
magique ça non plus il nous reste plus
de temps Stéphane mais je présume que il
y a des qualifications régulières
Antilles quand on est policier on va
parler pour le Québec il y a une
qualification annuelle qui est
obligatoire via le guide des pratiques
policières maintenant les pratiques qui
doivent accompagner ça bien sont
vraiment à chaque heure de police de le
faire et si on peut parler du respectvm
malheureusement
c'est un petit peu les l'enfant en
pauvre au niveau des pratiques dans les
dernières années allons-y Laval les
policiers peuvent tirer environ 200
balles par année et à Montréal
au niveau de la pratique on peut compter
50 balles c'est pas tous les policiers
qui pratiquent et c'est 50 bars pour la
qualification donc il y a du travail à
faire de ce côté-là il y a seulement
deux salles de tir également pour les
policiers à Mont stéphanois merci
infiniment de cette entrevue merci bonne
journée au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI